so one of the house republicans calling
for border crisis hearings joins me now
ohio congressman jim jordan and he's the
ranking member of the judiciary
committee
so congressman jordan uh you sent that
letter
to house democrats on the judiciary
committee i'm curious have you have you
heard back yet
no no and i'm sure we won't i mean we
ask for a hearing
they they won't have a hearing on the
border crisis in fact they haven't had
we've been in congress now 75 days and
the full judiciary committee hasn't had
a hearing on
anything not one hearing on on any
subject but this idea that it's not a
crisis is just laughable i mean if it
wasn't so serious it would be laughable
you got gang members crossing the border
you got people crossing the borders
whose names appear
on the terrorist watch list you got
covet positive people crossing the
border a hundred thousand encounters in
february alone
14 000 migrant children being housed in
the dallas convention center
talking about putting them in nasa
facilities i mean this
is a crisis if there ever was one and
frankly
we knew it was going to happen in fact
president trump said two months ago
before he left office
if you undo the policies we put in place
there will be quote
a tidal wave of illegal immigrants
coming to the border
so the right he was how right he was so
the white house
still calling it a challenge but not a
crisis and now you have house speaker
nancy pelosi
saying this what i think that the
administration is pulling this thing
under control and i think it's important
to know that
the the difference between the attitude
toward the people and the children
is so different in just these two months
versus what happened in the past four
years that
biden administration has this
under control congressman i'm assuming
you do not think they have it under
control
no again the american people realize
that is just that is just wrong
just flat out wrong just go back those
numbers i talked about 14 000 migrant
kids have to use the dallas convention
center they're talking about flying kids
to the northern
northern states in our in our country
now because the problem is so bad
and what's their answer this past week
they passed two bills that give amnesty
to three million illegals so that's only
going to exacerbate the problem
and entice more people to come to the
country and as as leader mccarthy
pointed out
what happens to so many of these kids
and women as they travel as cartels are
involved
is so wrong that is why it is certainly
a crisis
and we need to go back to the policies
that president trump had in place
as for what happens to a lot of these
migrant families and children
once they're here in the united states
uh listen to what texas governor greg
abbott said about the kinds of
conditions
that they're being kept in right now and
what they're dealing with
what i learned in just the past hour
shows that we are now dealing with
a humanitarian disaster more than 10
percent of the migrant population
at that location has tested positive for
cover 19.
so know this and that is any time we're
dealing with the
massive amount of influx of people
coming across the border
that would be a humanitarian crisis
and a big challenge the governor also
said at that
at least at that one facility that they
did not have access to to clean water
what's your response to that
well they reversed the policies that
president trump had put in place
this the the remain in mexico process so
we could evaluate before they come in
they reverse that the deportation of
people they've stopped that even
criminals they've stopped that
and then of course stop building the
wall that's the problem you got to put
those policies back in place they're
common sense they work
and they they're going to have when
those are back in place you won't have
this
this terrible crisis terrible treatment
of people that we currently see
all right congressman jordan thank you
so much for joining us on a friday have
a great weekend
you too thanks